16 lehrlinge aus der flieger werft 3 in
hörsching sind heute am 12
märz bei verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner zu besuch anlass ist die
überreichung des abschlusszeugnisses an
zwei absolventen des lehrberufs
luftfahrzeug technik zur sicherstellung
von nachwuchs beim fachpersonal autos
bundesheer bereits 2002 mit einer
eigenen lehrlingsausbildung im
fachbereich luft fahrzeugtechnik in
zeltweg begonnen
2017 implementiert auch die flieger war
auf drei dieser lehrlingsausbildung
die beiden sind somit die ersten
lehrlinge die diese lehrausbildung bei
der flieger wave 3 abgeschlossen haben
geschraubt wird hier vor allem an den
hubschrauber agusta bell 212 und der
arbeit 3 genau das richtige für die
technikbegeisterte absolventen
sehr jung war und ich habe eben auch
schon früher mit meinem vater viel
darüber reden wir nochmal technik berlin
werden und dann bin ich eben durch
zufall auf die lehrer schlossen
sozusagen im internet und dann habe ich
mich dafür entschieden dass ich luft hat
technikerin werden möchte
sie möchte auf jeden fall beim
bundesheer bleiben und hat auch schon
eine jobzusage in der triebwerks zentral
werkstätte der flieger wave 3 auch ihr
kollege schmid jo schmid schon fix
posten
bereich arbeiten
und so schnell wie möglich umstellen
wollen neben dem lehrabschluss geschenk
gibt es für die lehrlinge der flieger
werk 3 noch eine zusätzliche anerkennung
wir haben für die ausgezeichneten der
folge zweimal demütig vermittlung da
haben wir dann bis zum darstellen
darunter mehr zurückkommen
auch verteidigungsminister in tanna gibt
es ein anerkennungs geschenkt die beiden
lehrlinge überreichen wie eine selbst
angefertigte tisch ein ganz besonders
schönes geschenk und am heutigen tag
einfach nur stolz auf die jugend auf
diejenigen die bei uns ihre lehrzeit
absolvieren auf diejenigen die sich
schon fertig mit besonderen leistungen
ausgezeichnet und guter erfolg wir sind
stolz auf unsere lehrlinge und auf
unsere luft fahrzeugtechnik oder
techniker das österreichische bundesheer
belieben flugzeug technikern auch viele
andere fachkräfte und spezialisten osten
nur wenige wissen dass das
österreichische bundesheer zu den
größten lehrlingsausbildner erzählt was
zeichnet uns aus wir bilden in über 40
verschiedenen lehrberufen aus und wir
machen das auf eine ganz besondere art
und weise man ist hier tatsächlich wie
man es auch hier flieger wirft bei dann
gesehen hat man ist direkt vor ort
geschehen und unser bemühen ist
natürlich auch dass diejenigen denen
unser lehrkörper so viel an
aufmerksamkeit auch widmet dann
weiterhin dem bundesheer zur verfügung
stehen und das funktioniert ganz gut